a judge will decide today whether to
release the names of jurors in bill
causes sexual assault trial in a motion
file Monday the prosecution argues
revealing their identities could make
selecting a fair and impartial jury more
difficult in Cosby's retrial the defense
agrees under Pennsylvania law the public
has the right to know their names
Jericka Duncan is at the courthouse in
Norristown Pennsylvania where the
sequestered jury deliberated for more
than 52 hours
Jericho good morning good morning that
alternate juror who was not able to
deliberate says he would have voted
though to convict Bill Cosby
mike.mccluskey was among the jurors
sequestered he says their hotel floor
was guarded by sheriffs and they
couldn't leave but with another trial
looming it's likely a new jury will have
to go through that process all over
again Pennsylvania state prosecutors
believe releasing the names of the
jurors in Bill Cosby's sexual assault
trial could impact jury selection in the
79 year old retrial former prosecutor
Dennis McAndrew there's a concern that
if the public sees a great deal of
publicity around the jurors that it may
have an effect on future jurors and
create a smaller jury pool of willing
participants in the next trial the Cosby
not to go during the first trial jurors
were sequestered they lived in a hotel
hundreds of miles from home were only
allowed limited cell phone use and could
not discuss the trial outside of court
the judge every day would walk in and
you would pull you in one by one and ask
you did you find anything out during a
radio interview Monday alternate juror
mike mckowski described the bus ride
home after the judge declared a mistrial
we went to talk about it it was complete
silence it was the craziest arias plus
one I've ever taken
sequestration is a rare court order
given in high-profile cases attorney
Robert Shapiro was part of a Jay Simpson
so-called dream team it's very very
unique to have a jury sequestered during
the trial phase itself
it's rare to have jurors sequestered
during deliberations not guilty of the
crime of murder and during Simpsons 1995
murder trial jurors spent nearly nine
months closed off from the outside world
when the newspapers arrived in the
morning any article about OJ had been
totally cut out JoEllen Demetrius a jury
consultant on Simpson's trial says judge
Lance Ito tried to keep the jurors happy
he had every fine restaurant in Los
Angeles provide meals for these jurors
he also arranged field trips for the
jurors he arranged a trip we'll go to
Catalina for a weekend attorney Dennis
McAndrew says even if the names of the
Cosby jurors aren't released their
identities are likely to be revealed
their family their friends their
colleagues know they were on the jury so
I think that their identities are going
to be learned one way or the other
today's hearing will address privacy
issues the concern is that if you make
some of those private details those
deliberations public it may deter future
new jurors from serving that motion
hearing is expected to begin at 3:00
this afternoon Jeff all right Joe Rica
Duncan's drinka thank you very much